[Música]
Georgia meloni juró el cargo de primera
ministra de Italia su mandato supone el
regreso de la extrema derecha al poder
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial melón y
ya presentó su ejecutivo Tenemos reporte
desde Roma
en China concluyó el vigésimo congreso
del partido comunista la renovación del
comité central podría afianzar al
presidente en el poder y asegurarle un
tercer mandato al frente del gigante
asiático tenemos análisis en esta
edición
el ex Primer Ministro británico Boris
Johnson regresó a Londres en momentos en
los que se especula sobre sus
intenciones de volver a domin Street los
aspirantes a reemplazar a listras tienen
hasta el lunes para recaudar los apoyos
necesarios por ahora el exministro de
finanzas
lidera la carrera
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empecemos esta edición en Europa porque
la ultraderechista Georgia melonim juró
el cargo de primera ministra de Italia
se convierte así en la primera mujer en
ocupar el cargo y a la vez su mandato
implica el regreso de la extrema derecha
al poder desde la caída del régimen de
Benito Mussolini nuestra corresponsal en
Roma Natalia Mendoza tiene los detalles
sobre la conformación del nuevo
ejecutivo a menos de un mes de las
últimas elecciones legislativas en
Italia este sábado se llevó a cabo el
juramento del nuevo gobierno italiano
Georgia melón y la líder del partido de
ultraderecha posfacista hermanos de
Italia da así inicio a su mandato junto
con un gabinete de 24 ministros 18
hombres y seis mujeres entre los que se
destacan Antonio tayán y ex presidente
del parlamento euro nombrado canciller y
Vice Primer Ministro también Mateo
salvín y líder del partido de
ultraderecha la liga nombrado vicepre
Primer Ministro y ministro de
infraestructuras otro dirigente de la
liga Giancarlo georgetti estará al
frente del Ministerio de economía se
trata del gobierno más derechista en
Italia desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
Georgia melón y nacida en Roma hace 45
años se convierte en la primera mujer al
poder en la historia democrática de
Italia deberá afrontar numerosos
desafíos el control de las finanzas
públicas en un país profundamente
endeudado la lucha contra el desempleo y
la administración del fondo de
recuperación europeo Italia es el estado
que más dinero europeo va a recibir unos
200 mil millones de euros en préstamos y
subvenciones otorgados a Italia por
parte de la Unión Europea a cambio de
llevar a cabo un programa ambicioso de
reformas
a continuación repasamos el contexto
político en el que irrumpen el poder La
coalición Italiana de derecha y de
extrema derecha el informe es dele
laurel
el nuevo gobierno de Italia será
recordado por ser la administración más
conservadora desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y la victoria de la coalición de
la derecha en los comicios legislativos
del 25 de septiembre no solo hizo
triunfar a Georgia meloni con su partido
los hermanos de Italia como el más
votado que ahora asumirá el cargo de
primera ministrar el país después de los
comicios las cámaras del parlamento
también eligieron a dos presidentes con
valores ultraconservadoras
primero el senador la cámara alta eligió
a Ignacio la rusa como su líder
cofundador de los hermanos de Italia con
melón y este siciliano de 75 años ha
sido un activista de la extrema derecha
durante toda su vida antiguo ministro de
defensa de berlusconi la rusa es También
conocido por coleccionar recuerdos
fascistas y al día siguiente la cámara
baja de diputados dominó a lo Renzo
Fontana como presidente un estrecho
Aliado de salvini y devoto católico
conocido por sus posiciones antiaorto
contra el matrimonio homosexual y por
sus comentarios amistosos con la Rusia
de Vladimir putino a pesar del perfil
mayoritariamente conservador de este
nuevo parlamento italiano ya se han
observado tensiones dentro de la
coalición gubernamental con los partidos
de Silvio berlusconi y Mateo salvini
negándose a desaparecer detrás de
Georgia meloni una nueva administración
que llega además en un contexto de
desafíos para la tercera economía de la
zona Euro incluida una deuda que ha
alcanzado el 150% de su pib una recesión
inminente y precios récord en la energía
provocados por la Guerra de Ucrania
cambiamos ahora de información porque
tal y como avanzamos en los titulares en
China se clausuró el vigésimo congreso
del partido comunista con la elección de
un nuevo comité central del que saldrá
el nuevo polit buró y el nuevo comité
permanente tras los cambios en este
congreso se espera que el actual
mandatario
afiance su poder al frente de la
formación que dirige al gigante asiático
ahora para analizar las principales
conclusiones de este congreso Contamos
con Alex Sierra politólogo e
internacionalista Álex buenos días Le
propongo que analicemos las conclusiones
de este congreso por partes primero en
términos de liderazgo de shift por un
lado porque ha sacado al Premier League
del comité central
Bueno muy buenos días para todos
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación Yo
pienso que esto hace parte precisamente
del cambio el rejuvenecimiento que
quiere el presidente para garantizar
precisamente un liderazgo dentro del
partido pienso que ahí hay varios temas
entre ellos uno es el envejecimiento
precisamente de parte del comité central
otro punto puede ser ya los temas de
jubilación Entonces en ese aspecto es
importante que el presidente tenga
precisamente como como una línea
inquebrantable del camino del desarrollo
político el socialismo y por eso se
piensa que él hace estos cambios para
garantizar Obviamente el funcionamiento
y el desempeño del papel del partido
como tal dentro de estas políticas que
él quiere a futuro y Alex abordemos
ahora los cambios en el ámbito militar y
de unidad nacional Como por ejemplo la
oposición explícita a la independencia
de Taiwán en la constitución del partido
en qué medida las conclusiones de este
congreso significan un cambio o sigue en
una línea más bien continuista
Bueno yo pienso que el presidente ha
hecho algunos cambios específicamente en
este último congreso donde él reitera
que es partidario de la unidad
específicamente de la reunificación
pacífica con Taiwán pero que él estaría
dispuesto a utilizar el uso de la fuerza
él tiene como ejemplo pues lo que ha
sucedido entre Ucrania y Rusia y no
quiere cometer esos errores y él dice
que efectivamente Esto hace parte de que
se tiene que resolver de una forma
pacífica entonces lo que estamos viendo
Es que él busca que el pueblo chino sea
el que tome la decisión y no haya
injerencia internacional hay que esperar
que va a pasar en los próximos meses ya
sabiendo que él va a ser reelegido
Entonces se va a revisar como esa
política militar va a cambiar pero él
mantiene es la reunificación como tal
con Taiwán y ahora un paréntesis uno de
los episodios más comentados de la
sesión de hoy ha sido cuando fuerzas de
seguridad sacaron de la sala al ex
presidente hushingto se especula entre
cuestiones de salud del ex mandatario y
el que podría ser un acto inédito de
purga pública lo ve posible
Yo pienso que más un tema de purga
pública porque son contradictores
personas que de pronto no están a favor
de algunas medidas del presidente
Entonces yo creo que esa cena marca un
poco netamente lo que fue ese congreso
cierto el cambio vuelvo a reitero el
cambio de de rejuvenecer este partido y
algunas políticas Que obviamente el
presidente quiere implementar de su
partido entonces
miraremos a ver también cómo sucede esto
desde de mañana cuando se haga la
lección como tal y efectivamente Pues
para el mundo hay un claro mensaje de la
postura como tal del presidente ante sus
decisiones políticas sociales militares
y Alex cerremos en términos económicos
Cuáles son los objetivos de China para
el futuro por un lado respecto al nivel
de vida de su población y por otro
respecto a su papel de potencia global y
más particularmente puede china mantener
la política de Cero covid y aspirar al
mismo tiempo al crecimiento económico
Yo pienso que el presidente ha sido
claro su política de rejuvenecimiento
comercial que darle vida al tema rural
es una economía milenaria o es una
civilización entre la cual se ha
desarrollado permanentemente Así que la
propuesta de él es que para el 2030 2035
china debe ser la potencia mundial en el
mercado Por eso Abre ha abierto los
espacios en relaciones internacionales
permite que haya una una liberalización
una libertad económica cierto y eso va a
permitir también que china se consolide
en unos años Dentro de este marco
digamos comercial aludiendo
efectivamente que debe haber una
trazabilidad en cuanto lo que es el
manejo de la ciencia la tecnología y la
capacitación en el ámbito rural
alexierrada Muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo y por su análisis ustedes Muchas
gracias nosotros cambiamos de
información pasamos a Reino Unido porque
el ex Primer Ministro británico Boris
Johnson aterrizó en Londres tras unas
vacaciones en el Caribe la llegada de
Johnson refuerza las especulaciones
sobre sus intenciones de anunciar una
candidatura para regresar a Downey
Street los aspirantes a reemplazar a
listas tienen hasta el lunes para reunir
el apoyo de al menos 100 parlamentarios
conservadores de momento solo el
exministro de finanzas Richi sunat
cuenta con los avales necesarios y solo
la líder de los Stories en la cámara de
los comunes Penny Morgan ha confirmado
sus intenciones de conseguir el cargo
estaré diciendo primera ministra hasta
que se elija un sucesor
y para definir el sucesor de lizros el
partido conservadora elegido la vía
rápida después de las largas semanas de
campaña con múltiples candidatos esta
vez el umbral de patrocinios para ser
considerados se fija muy alto
los candidatos deben ser nominados por
al menos 100 diputados
el partido conservador tiene 357
diputados en la cámara lo que significa
que habrá un máximo de tres candidatos
entonces quién podría presentarse para
tomar la cabeza del partido mayoritario
en la cámara de los comunes y por lo
tanto ser nombrado Primer Ministro
primero los que perdieron con listros
de Hacienda elegido por los
parlamentarios Pero no por los miembros
del partido es el primero en haber
reunido los 100 apoyos Penny morton que
quedó en tercer lugar en las últimas
elecciones actual ministra de relaciones
con el parlamento cuenta con poco más de
y finalmente Boris Johnson varios
parlamentarios conservadores ya están
haciendo campaña por él y el actual
ministro de energía incluso lanzó la
etiqueta Boris o nada en Twitter el día
clave es el lunes los diputados
realizarán una primera votación para
eliminar a uno de los tres candidatos
luego votan el mismo día para nominar a
su candidato preferido a título
indicativo eso significa que o el que
llega segundo se retira o una vez más
los miembros del partido conservador
votarán al final de la próxima semana el
nombre del nuevo Primer Ministro
británico se conocerá a más tardar el
próximo viernes 28 de octubre
vamos ahora con información relacionada
con la guerra en Ucrania este sábado
kiev denunció nuevos ataques rusos
contra infraestructuras energéticas en
el oeste del país varias regiones
reportaron cortes eléctricos los ataques
se dan después de que el ministro de
energía ucraniano confirmará ayer que
las embestidas rusas han mermado la
capacidad de generación térmica del país
a la mitad los temores continúan
centrados aún en La Represa de Nova
kakova situada en el río nieper kiev ha
acusado a Rusia de haber minado el
puente y La Represa señalamiento negado
por las tropas de Moscú que a su vez
culpan a Ucrania de ataques en la zona
hoy las autoridades pre rusas de gerson
urgieron a los residentes a abandonar la
ciudad inmediatamente veamos el reporte
de Andrés triviño
continúa las evacuaciones en gerson con
pocas pertenencias y mucho temor miles
de residentes de esta ciudad del sur de
Ucrania huyen desesperados el ejército
ruso los instó a abandonar sus hogares
Durante los próximos días se espera que
el ejército de kiev realice una
contraofensiva para recuperar el terreno
anexionado por Moscú alrededor de 10
autobuses transportaban refugiados hoy
ayudamos tanto como pudimos movimos
cosas algunos fueron transportados en
minibús a la ciudad otros fueron
escoltados a estaciones suburbanas
Rusia planeaba actuar entre 50.000 y
60.000 personas de la urbe la cual tenía
unos
284.000 habitantes antes de ser invadida
por los rusos al principio de la guerra
Esta es una zona de alto interés para
ambos lados del conflicto se trata de un
objetivo principal debido a sus
industrias clave y Su importante Puerto
fluvial Durante los últimos días gerson
ha sido testigo de fuertes
enfrentamientos alrededor de 2.000 rusos
han llegado a la ciudad mientras las
fuerzas ucranianas continúan aumentando
la presión en la región
nos ofrecieron salir debido a la difícil
situación recibimos mensajes de texto
no no tomamos una decisión de inmediato
pero luego nuestros amigos y familiares
nos invitaron y ahora nos vamos a Moscú
esperamos tiempos mejores y queremos
volver a nuestro gerson natal
entre tanto Ucrania pidió el viernes una
misión de observación internacional en
la presa de jacobka kiefa acusa a moscúe
de preparar ataques que inundarían una
vasta zona del Sur ucraniano con esta
actualización del avance de la guerra en
Ucrania cerramos esta edición pero
recuerden que pueden ampliar esta y más
información en Francia 24 y Francia
24.com sigan con nosotros enseguida
volvemos
[Música]